on ne va pas commencer à parler qu'un
lointain pour toi parce que l'arrivée
d'un matelot de ce triste sire paris
essayez vous conseille
il est en pense le progrès on est
d'accord le camion met du temps à ça
c'est pas mal ça la vie est trop tôt là
la mise en scène est l'occasion
ouais d'accord je commence à apercevoir
le bleu la vraie activement ces minus un
petit avion very good selon ya pas de
carburant car il montre le versant
français qu'en fait non pas des jolies
encore à l'ail et les camions qui
arrivent là ouais ok sinon j'essaie
d'aller
on va couper le moteur
tu veux qu'ils avancent
baptisé hot tub ecover d'avancer
doucement pour le soleil est parti en
place un peu d'attenté et ouais je
n'intéresse fait